[Music]
today's question comes from shelly in
tennessee and shelley writes when we got
married my husband wanted to live on a
budget we paid off our house which is in
his name and lived debt free
two years ago he suddenly stopped living
on any type of budget his spending is so
extreme now that money has had to be
transferred from our savings to pay
bills several times
i had to separate my finances from his
and started working full time after he
continued to abuse our shared money and
threatened me with divorce
now he's demanding that i combine
finances again to get access to my
paycheck
i'm trying to save for an attorney in
housing if we divorce i'm not in a
dangerous situation so i'm not in a
hurry to divorce until i'm prepared
financially i don't want to hide funds
from the government but i do want to
hide funds from my spouse is there any
way i can protect myself financially
while pacifying
my spouse
nope nope
nope
this is um time for you to sit down with
a marriage counselor and with your
pastor and develop um
something more than a radio answer for
something that's important in your life
and uh but it sounds like that it's
gonna
what you're gonna develop with them is
the ability to have a conversation with
your husband that says
either this
or that if then now yeah
and uh it's called the ultimatum and
that's where you are
i think people often get abuse and
we think of physical safety
like i'm being hit
this woman is unsafe this is financial
that's right she's about psychologically
uncertain homeless she's a psychological
abuse this is highly trump this is a
terrible environment to be in a terrible
environment to be in if there is he's
obviously
involved in something right that's right
he's either an addict of some that's my
guess here he's an addict or he's with
somebody else or something who knows or
both or both that's right um and so my
the one thing i want to call out here is
the number of couples who are divorced
and live together and torture each other
they stay married but in spirit and in
finances and in life they are living two
separate lives they're already divorced
they just never admitted it yes
they
like you're prepping for a divorce
you're ready for divorce i'm not in a
hurry well honey you've already
crossed the line there then and now what
you're choosing to do is torture
yourself torture this guy who's clearly
gone off and it's just you've made a
mess this isn't something to just kind
of him a hall around you're not safe
he owns the house right all it's just a
mess get with somebody a professional
today he's a mess man yeah and and and
make a
a narrative up that says um
you don't stop this
we're done yeah
if i'm not safe to be in my own home
yeah if you you don't stop yeah the
extreme spending and you don't stop the
manipulation
and you don't stop
the out of control aspects of your life
we're done so
uh you know 30 years i i've been doing
this um
i'm going to give you a wild
but maybe not so wild guess
cocaine
this fits cocaine yeah it's hyper it's
hyped up
uh out of control
energetic
frenetic
he is
uh because everything he's doing he's
doing wide open and somewhat out of the
blue was this way is that randomly yeah
it just fits the fits the pattern for me
i'm i'm not a professional i'm just an
old guy that's seen a lot yeah and um
which is kind of the same thing by the
way but same exact thing that's that's
the definition of wisdom right
but yeah but i mean it could it may not
be it may be it may be a girlfriend it
may be a porn addiction this may there
may be 73 prostitutes in the background
on this but there's something extreme
yeah there's no little tiny
i'm having an emotional affair at the
office that's not here or a major
psychiatric is whatever some kind of
blow up schism
before
nuts here
and so i don't
based on that i i don't think when you
present the either or
that you're going to get an either
you're just going to get an ore
you're going to be gone and be ready for
that yeah you bet expect to be leaving
instantaneously
and uh go ahead and do that and you
don't need a house you just need an
apartment
you know you got a paycheck just take
your paycheck you've been living on that
anyway and if you've paid equity into
this home as part of the divorce
settlement he'll have to write you a
check yeah and if you see my kids he's
gonna have to write child support and if
you've been married a long time in most
states he's got the right alimony and
that's all part of the divorce and you
can get the attorney later it's you
don't have to stay there
and you shouldn't another minute you
need to go sit with someone
and have someone else look at this long
form not a two-minute radio answer this
is your life it is your marriage but
that's our perception reading in from
the outside that you got a mess on your
hands that does not it does appear to
have gone beyond
the point of no return but we'll see
maybe we're wrong maybe i'm wrong i hope
i'm wrong